Actor/Filmmaker Josh Folan: I'm Josh Folan and I've been making
independent film for over a decade now
mostly in New York as of set months ago
in LA and we just recently on
Thanksgiving released my ninth produced
fourth written third directed second
edited feature love is dead
starring Alice Primo Berg out Thompson
Lita Foster we did that in self
distribution fashion and self
distribution is a somewhat fluid term
with a lot of definitions and meanings
at least right now and this is our our
these are the five things that Film
Courage thinks I should share with you
about the at least initial stages of
that self distribution experience and
this is my fireplace the first thing I
would touch on about self distribution
is the decision to do it it's not the
easiest way okay you fill out into the
world it's a great deal of work so it's
not for everyone
in our case the reason we chose to do it
was a range of things but one it was
hard to attract interest in it from the
companies that you really want to be
working with or many of the companies
that you really want to be working with
in the distribution realm we had you
know an extremely difficult to sell
subject matter
you know most sales companies are not
looking to blaze new trails with the
material they acquire they want
something that's just like a thing they
know can sell but maybe just a little
bit different to differentiate it in the
marketplace and that you know it's
definitely what we made you be what you
touch your daughters yet you were here
quoting the Bible like you're not a
Whore
and on top of the subject matter we the
actual aesthetic of the film is weird we
shot the film to look like this 1970s or
80s television sitcom so it's shot in a
four by three aspect ratio we degraded
the 4k image to make it look standard
definition and look like it's playing
off this shitty VHS tape there's
commercial breaks and opening title
sequence there's just a range of things
that make it not look like anything that
really is out there in my opinion which
I can send that to me an asset but sales
companies are a little more hesitant
with something like that so it was
difficult to get a partner that we
really liked
we did get interest from smaller
companies that you know so I'm not so
bad some bad and the reason you know the
smaller company like that in my
experience having done this for a decade
isn't going to do anything they're not
gonna bring the added value to the
project they're gonna throw it on the
platforms which a chimpanzee could do in
this day and age and you know
they're not gonna put any marketing
behind it they're not gonna do anything
special so why give them in most cases
you're gonna have to give away like 30
percent of your revenue off the gross -
expenses that they're gonna deduct from
going to fill markets and where they may
or may not be really doing anything for
your film so we didn't want to give away
that much for that little so we decided
or I decided maybe initially and got
Shaunie my co-producer to agree to it to
just do it ourselves and and I have self
distributed before so I thought this
time around that I could perhaps do it
for little to no money which is what we
had left over from our
two and a half thousand dollar budget
and you know there are some sacrifices
we had to make and I would direct you to
the article I wrote for film courage
that led to me having to make this video
reading that you can decide whether all
this work and the potential payoff for
it is for you but for us it made the
most sense the second thing about self
distribution for zero dollars in
particular that I would touch on is the
assets required and in turn the skills I
think you need to have or have cheap to
free access to in order to accomplish
this one of the things you're going to
need
especially in a market place where
everyone's just you know blowing through
a million different titles and whatever
platform they watch their content on is
a really good key art that captures what
the film is about and is compelling and
one way or another and you know set you
somehow apart from the other things that
they could be picking and in our case
with our key art for love is dead we you
know you first of all you got any
producing 101 you need to have an on-set
photographer that's taking pictures
however you you know whether you're
paying them or begging for favors out of
photographers or however you get it you
need to have the actual imagery in order
to create key art with in our case this
picture was captured by our key and only
PA and associate producer slash art
department assistant slash a million
other things utility infielder Josh
goldsmith that's where we got the image
from and then I tinkered around with in
Photoshop with it to get it to this and
then for actual delivery you're going to
need to reformat it into a million
different aspect ratios for the
aggregators and platforms all require
different specs on that so you need to
have some photoshop acumen you also need
some editing acumen I think I think you
know deaden the film and the trailer
both in this case for marking materials
the trailer but I think in order to
achieve low-budget slash micro budget
filmmaking in general a director a
writer director also needs to be able to
edit their stuff because if you're
outsourcing that it's either going to
cost you money or you're going
you seen the shit out of whoever you're
begging for the favors out of because
it's a long arduous process to edit so
for the purposes of marketing materials
editing the trailer and being able to
deliver that and again multiple formats
for whatever platforms aggregators are
requiring it is also a skill you need to
have
you'll also need captions a caption file
for pretty much all platforms these days
require that closed captions and you can
either we paid for it it's one of the
few things we did spend money on because
I have done it for the batteries not
included this Amazon Doc series I
created and direct edit and also for all
God's creatures my very first written
produced feature and the caption euro
the captioning stuff is just the worst
job and most painstakingly boring and
worst job in the universe in my opinion
so my heart goes out to the people in
rev.com who I usually outsource this to
they do it for a dollar a minute so
that's one area I would recommend even
if it's only out of your pocket to spend
a few bucks but you will need to deliver
that one way or another and you can
Google of course how that the format you
need for the srt delivery syntax slash
whatever format so the third thing about
substituting love is dead for $0 are
relatively any ways that I would touch
on is who we partnered with to do it
there are quite a few options out there
these days for aggregating and getting
on you know the various platforms some
of which you can do yourselves some you
can't and that's you know not really for
a video or I'm talking to your face you
can Google all that and find out for
yourself but the companies companies
plural that we chose to work with and
that I've worked with a bunch of times
for library titles isn't the first time
I'm releasing initially with them but
film hub which is just film hub comm and
a partner of theirs that I've also
worked with separately bid slate which
is also just bits like com and they're
both companies that do a service a
number of platforms
film hub 100 well over 100 worldwide and
they charge no fees upfront whatsoever
and they do take it cut on the back end
both of them I'm pretty sure our 80/20
so they take 20% off gross revenue
received via platforms with them but
they're not exclusive so you can you
know if you want to do certain platforms
certain territories whatever you can cut
those off and figure those out yourself
and just work with with bits later film
hub on whatever specific things you want
to work with them on so that
non-exclusive thing is very attractive
to me and obviously no cost up front for
the purposes of the $0 self distribution
is very attractive as well and I would
highly recommend looking into both of
them before thing I would get into is
marketing and this is probably the area
that is most differentiated between self
distribution and working with a
distributor you know the only way
eyeballs are or are not getting on your
film and actually generate revenue is by
way of your own work and spreading the
word and getting people to realize that
your film even exists and you know every
there's a million options with this and
I couldn't begin to list them all here
either in the article I wrote for film
courage or in this video but I can touch
on a few of things that I am doing for
love is dead and will continue to do and
have done for many of if not all my past
projects as well one of the things is
hometown press you know if you're from a
small town assume you're not from a big
you know major metropolis I'm from
Overland Ohio and Oberlin Ohio being a
city or a town of 2,000 people when the
college is not in session 10,000 when it
is there haven't been a whole lot of
filmmakers to come out of there so it's
that is certainly a marketplace that you
want to hit because these are people
that have known you all your life and at
least probably hopefully find it
somewhat cool that's
in Ohio is out doing this with their
life so you know I always reach back and
talk to the local radio station in the
local newspaper surrounding newspapers
you might even be able to weasel your
way onto a local news television program
so you know reaching out at least trying
to to generate that interest both
because it should be easier for you to
attract the attention of and because
it's also just a marketplace a
demographic people that have known you
forever and hopefully like you at least
a little our potential sales so that's
one thing
the independent blog and filmmaking
podcast and blogging community are other
places you can reach out to there's a
million filmmaker film courage is an
example of one of course but there are
many others that you can reach out to
and you know they're always looking
podcasts hosts are always looking for
new guests people who are actually
making things happen making films so
don't be afraid to reach out and try to
tell your story with and via them as
well
there's also you know a read it is
probably one of the bigger best examples
of it but there are there are other ways
to contribute to the independent
filmmaking conversation or just the film
enthusiast and general conversation a
read is fantastic because it you know
subdivides these demographics into
individual communities where the
conversations are happening that you can
participate in you got to be careful you
can't just go in there and just
shamelessly self promote you have to be
an actual live human being and
participate in the conversation to bring
added value to it not just saying hey
watch my stupid shit so you know that
but if you are adding value to the
conversation you certainly can still
talk about your projects and use them as
examples and that be a benefit to to the
people that you're
sharing that stuff with and they also
have the AMA thing which is you know
they asked me anything option which I
usually do with projects sometimes it's
more well received in others but you
know you did something very hard you
made a feature film and not everyone has
achieved that and the people who are
trying to and want to achieve that are I
know I was just endlessly looking for
easier ways tips tricks whatever just
trying to find help to get them to a
place where they can even begin but let
alone finish the process of making a
their own feature film so sharing your
experience is one way to again share
your projects the fifth and final thing
I would get into about self distribution
particularly for $0 is the understanding
that the problem never goes away and
this kind of goes back to the first
point about whether self distribution is
right for you but you do need to have an
understanding going into it that you
will always have to be the one working
to monetize this film at least if you're
doing your job and keeping your promise
to your investors that you're you know
going to try to maximize the revenue the
film generates and you know there are
projects even where we had to distribute
all God's creatures we got a distributor
in the initial stages and you know we
still had to both help them roll the
film out and we have since gotten all
rights back and I am now or we are now
on a daily basis trying to find ways to
monetize that film and and love is dead
we absolutely doing that and ongoing
capacity to so just an understanding
that you know you need to be working or
to be doing your job anyways the
everyday you're working to find new ways
and especially the digital distribution
landscape there's you know new platforms
popping up every day and new ways to to
achieve monetization so you know the
if this is most applicable I think in
the sense that you know a lot of
filmmakers want to be making films and
not distributing films so I think an
understanding that today's modern
filmmaker independent filmmaker is also
at least a little bit of a distributor
too and you need to accept that and
embrace it I think to really be
successful doing stuff are doing this
stuff rather so those are my five things
I would want to convey about self
distributing and I recommend you again
read the full article that I wrote on
this topic for film courage and check
out both love is dead it's on Amazon now
and then be on demand and the rest of my
stuff @n yeh entertainment.com
and thanks for watching me ramble for
however long you watch this
you